why'd you walk in so mad though there  was a gas leak my wife calls me at 9am  saying hey there's a gas leak in the  house so I go home before I get to my  front door I can smell gas oh no so it  was really [ __ ] bad I'm pissed  hurting are you dangerous huh is it are  you dangerous  are you in dangerous  I think I wasn't danger and I look at  the oven and it's just on oh my God the  light was on because it's like that's  not a gas leaked I mean someone left it  on no we haven't touched the oven bro we  touched it then nobody Cooks in the  house nobody well I cook in the house  your dog touched it no no no it we  didn't touch it someone touched the knob  the nozzle you got me a [ __ ] liar  dude it just opens by itself maybe  you're [ __ ] hot that's like a [ __ ]  billionaire with your cool ass [ __ ]  oven it's just turned on by itself  make this cap come off by itself how  about that oh [ __ ]  by itself